comment vit-il je suis très content de
t'entendre emmanuel comme convenu je
décide de mener notre rencontre
aujourd'hui en visioconférence comme tu
le sais le 24 juin nous avons organisé
le défilé militaire en l'honneur de la
fin de la grande guerre patriotique
comme nous appelons cette stratégie donc
cette tragédie donc c'est en fait notre
victoire commune est ici en russie
nous n'oublierons jamais les français
qui ont lutté à nos côtés sur le front
de l'est avec l'armée rouge s'agit du
normandie niemen mais aussi dans
d'autres détachements militaires et de
même que des milliers de citoyens
soviétiques ont lutté dans les rangs de
la résistance française et tout cela
c'est notre héritage en commun
aujourd'hui nous sommes confrontés à de
nouvelles menaces et l'une d'entre elles
c'est l'affection accorde un virus et
pour cette raison nous n'arrivons pas
tenir une réunion dans un cadre normal
mais aujourd'hui nous avons peut-être
dans cette nouvelle forme contemporaine
deux formats de discussions mais les
menaces ancien entier ancien continue à
exister elles n'ont pas disparu
il s'agit du terrorisme l'immigration
incontrôlée
les changements climatiques la pandémie
dans l'ensemble dans le sens le plus
large de ce terme est et toutes les
menaces qu'elle suppose pour l'humanité
et c'est aussi malheureusement la
destruction des systèmes de contrôle des
armements et tout cela ensemble c'est
notre ordre du jour et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui nous allons discuter de
tout cela et de tout ce que j'ai énuméré
nous nous allons aussi parler des points
chauds dans le globe et des menaces
croissance nous allons parler de
l'ukraine de la situation dans les
balkans en syrie en libye et je sais que
tout cela te preuve que possible et
d'ailleurs à propos justement
aujourd'hui c'est le jour
c'est la date de la signature de
documents fondateurs des nations unies
dont il ya 75 ans donc encore une fois
l'union des efforts pour résoudre les
problèmes qui se posent de façon
générale général si nous voulons obtenir
un résultat positif nous devons unir nos
efforts je sais que tu es d'accord et
que tu as l'intention de faire en sorte
que nous travaillons ensemble et je ne
peux que soutenir la proposition et je
suis convaincu qu'aujourd'hui nous
allons travailler de façon utile mais
encore une fois je tiens à confirmer
réty réitérer mon invitation à toi
président de l'ape les françaises de te
rendre en russie pour une discussion
sous un format tout à fait complet c'est
sûr que c'est d'abord l'occasion pour
moi te dire à moore le tibet ou non pas
de dire je comprends c'est raciste mon à
l'endos durement éprouvés par la
pandémie du communisme attendait le plan
sanitaire et inoubliable et parce qu'ils
espèrent signer solidaire c'est ce virus
qui nous empêchait de bosnie il ya deux
jours ici tu ne me le rappeler ce qui
change intervient à un moment important
pour la russie près serré
foire lycée mounier par le machisme
j'aurais voulu être présent physiquement
à tirer son physique et mathématiques
celui-ci te revenir en tout cas comme je
te l'avais écrit le 9 mai la tête
l'hommage de la france c'est avec au
fond cette conscience du temps long que
nous avons ensemble la valeur comme toi
ta crise que nous avons traversée notre
important sachant que le faire de la
situation appelant au sens large puisque
une heure les tables espace de co l'un
comme l'autre ont une importance j'ai
dit oui je te dirais trop de mon coeur
c'est l'inter le permettent il est
accusé de la mort et je serai très
heureux de te rencontrer bienvenus